[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je pense que tu as déjà ta chronique
pour la semaine prochaine
on peut le faire tout de suite alors
incroyable
je suis très heureux dans un instant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
magnifique Jean-Marie ça va ça va tout
va bien
je me régale
du clash et du kif et il y a de la
chanson mais on commence comme chaque
semaine avec tout ce qui se passe
pendant les pubs tout ce que vous voyez
pas à la télé c'est la Gazette des
offres
[Rires]
on continue avec vous Cyril visiblement
vous avez une partie de corps qui est
déjà en hiver
ils ont toujours aussi pro et informé
sur vos invités salut comment ça va
merci beaucoup
carlaration
bon pour la prochaine séquence
franchement j'ai pas de lancement Cyril
se suffit à lui-même regarde
mais Valérie Bénaïm a complètement lâché
les chevaux
un petit poulet aux épinards
aurais-tu l'amabilité de fermer ta
gueule
MMA menteur manipulateur et arrogant
c'est Mathieu Delormeau bien sûr
ça reprend je suis de gauche
et on termine avec Benjamin toujours
aussi charismatique tout tout le monde
adore ces maths
en culotte
merci Sacha
non mais c'est un truc de ouf c'est
vraiment la vanne de l'oncle oh là là
calme-toi respecte les artistes
ici enfin deux d'ailleurs non non non il
y a la croix
ça va ouais moi je suis content de
revoir mon pote Benji
et toi tu as c'est pas un ex mais nous
on se connaît
le dernier d'ailleurs
c'est pour s'aimer directement en fait
il faut détester
c'est souvent comme ça on commence par
et après on s'aime
j'adore
mais en fait j'ai vu t'aimer parce que
en fait c'est le boss la vie
comment tu la vois toi avec tes petits
yeux
[Rires]
faite elle est interpréter voilà c'est
pas grave
[Applaudissements]
on a beaucoup de similitudes parce que
voilà
et c'est pour ça vous voulez pas vous
appeler après
pendant quelques années
merci allez c'est toujours
il y a beaucoup de débats puisque ça
déborde sur le plateau et qui dit débat
dit parfois bah ça se frites clash etc
mais ça redescend toujours très vite et
ben il y a une autre séquence qui est
mythique dans TPMP que vous adorez c'est
quoi la suite pour vous faire plaisir
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait j'ai réuni les
deux j'ai réuni un peu de clash un peu
de quoi la suite et on commence avec un
débat très vif qui a eu la semaine
dernière mes cartes de sandwich depuis
s'interroge sur le vaccin c'est pas un
complotiste justement et je crois
si on te dit de ne pas inviter quelqu'un
et contre ma coupe pression tu vas le
dire
on continue dans un instant à tout de
suite on va jouer un jeu comment va
réagir Béatrice à ce débat réponse a
décidé de mettre une clé à tous les
chroniqueurs réponse B ils sont Bob avec
Total puisqu'elle au casting de
Spider-Man 8
bon visiblement il est embrouille mais
comment on va réagir Valérie Benaim
juste à côté réponse a elle s'en ouvre
totalement parce qu'elle a un couscous
boulette avec patoche réponse B elle est
complètement aboubina
[Applaudissements]
bon finalement comment ça va se finir
tout ça réponse ah ça va partir en slata
méchouia sur le plateau TPMP réponse
TPMP
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon ça va ça va mieux tout ça va mieux
ça va mieux
oui ça va mieux
on continue avec Benjamin Castaldi
pourquoi ah je rappelle qu'il a triché
la semaine dernière Benjamin Castaldi du
coup vous avez pris la décision de
partir un peu les six à 7 et n'oubliez
pas etc mais c'est un peu rester là ah
Benjamin regardez
ces deux six à 7 ça me fait un peu de
poignard
bon alors ça aussi quoi
[Musique]
ce petit tac réponse a il va lui faire
ses plus plates excuses réponse B il va
lui [ __ ] sa race
j'essaye un truc que j'aime oublier le
jour où je me suis viré il y a six
personnes qui ont dit non pour m'en
passer tu as dit oui tout de suite donc
ça mon petit bonhomme je peux dire que
ton fils à 7 je vais le prendre mais
bientôt il faut
oh là là là
[Musique]
c'est normal tu es une merde oh là là tu
es une merde simple efficace et
tellement vrai mais visiblement Mathieu
Delormeau et une solution pour que tout
le monde soit content regarde attention
du coup c'est un peu moins c'est 80
euros
je garde ta bagnole demain tu prends un
PVT
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
est une artiste vous en êtes un vous
aussi un très grand artiste
bien j'aime bien
allez vas-y là vas-y t'emmerde pas avec
ça joli collier on a pas avec ça
vous êtes un artiste j'ai envie de dire
un artiste pourquoi un artiste parce que
vous êtes découvert un nouveau talent
faire des reprises à votre manière sur
la tête de ma mère c'est un petit bijoux
incroyable après avoir été animateur
producteur humoriste et joueurs de
paddle Cyril Hanouna devient
transformiste j'ai envie de faire Johnny
Azoulay ils sont toutes les chansons de
Johnny Hallyday
découvrez toutes les chansons de Johnny
Hallyday avec un accent tunisien retiens
la nuit
ah ouais quand même mais encore vous
connaissez dadjuif notez lever au rang
de reine au rang de reine au rang de
reine
assez parlé c'est d'être juif quel
phénomène mais où peut-on bien retrouver
toutes ces chansons
dans un album exclusif validé par le
beddine avec des artistes comme Matt
Pokora dingue Christophe maézuza Atik
Shana ainsi que de sulfureux Booba
mitsbar les reprises de Baba un album
Universal au monde
on est Monsieur
qui a une partie divertissement une
partie actuelle on peut passer d'une
danse d'affilateur Nord un fait divers
en 20 minutes c'est la force de TPMP et
donc une séquence qu'on adore c'est de
regarder comparer un peu ce qui se fait
dans le PAF ça s'appelle le pendant ce
temps-là on adore
18h40 scène d'amour sur TV novelas
[Musique]
tu me rends fou
18h40 autre genre de scène d'amour sur
C8
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
échange d'idées sur Public Sénat l'homme
qui ne fait pas respecter les
occupés
le débat échange d'idées sur ces mythes
comme vous pouvez le voir je suis arrivé
à un contrôle parfait moi total contrôle
de moi-même 20h15 c'est l'heure de
l'édito de Joseph bien sûr qu'on connaît
sur KTO TV
bonjour à tout le monde un nouveau pays
est né il s'agit évidemment du lister
bourg
à la même heure autre genre d'édito sur
TPMP je vais vous montrer tout de suite
ça donne ça
bonjour Jordan Bardella bonjour vous
avez sans doute vu cette image et quand
on accueille nous un homme politique sur
C8 bah ça donne ça dans un instant il
sera avec nous barre des là Jordan
bardea
bonjour Jordan Bardella bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]